he's in his sixth year in the national
football league but for the first
as the quarterback of the detroit lions
the 2016 first
overall pick in the nfl draft now number
one
in the uh in the hearts and minds of the
honolulu blue jared gough here on the
rich eisen show how are you jared
i'm good race thanks for having me how
are you doing i'm hanging in there man i
remember being a new yorker showing up
in the state of michigan
um back in 1986 and learning the ways of
the beautiful midwest and
and uh you know stuff like uh you don't
say
uh sneakers you say tennis shoes you
don't say soda you say pop are you
are you going through all that as a
californian now showing up yeah i'm
going
to transition right now as we speak it's
been fun though i've enjoyed my time out
here
so far and really got to know some of
the people and uh the weather is great
it's a lot of fun out here okay so the
adjustment process
other than that has been what for you
for a kid from california playing his
ball
collegiately and uh professionally in
california now they're in
in michigan uh yeah i mean that's
that's been the easy part i think you
know obviously the football parts the
stuff that i've been focused on and
trying to you know catch up with the
playbook and and get acclimated to
the building and everyone here and um
it's been fun though i've really enjoyed
it the people here are incredible
um dan tired such a great staff everyone
around him so good and
it's been a lot of fun man all right so
let's let's talk about your uh
your coach there and dan campbell we've
seen what he's uh what he's like in
front of a microphone at the podium
um is he biting kneecaps off in practice
and stuff like that too
or is it a little different you know i
don't i don't know i think i think what
i will say about him though
is everything is genuine you know he
he's had the the fun stuff on
on the press conferences but it is who
he is it's out of passion
it's genuine it's authentic and it's the
same way he is every day with us
it's a lot of fun to play for him and to
be around him and um
you know he comes off that way but i'll
tell you this he's as smart as he is
um you know fun to be around no i know i
i definitely
he also has the mentality of of a former
player
in the nfl and i just saw him and the
rest of the staff
chest bumping and chest thumping on the
lions camera that we had during the
draft
when penae sewell was drafted uh if
there was a camera on you what would we
have seen
after he was drafted in the first round
yeah i was fired up uh you know
anytime you get someone to to protect
you that's always fun and and penae was
um i think by all accounts the top
alignment in the draft and for us to get
him and
him in the building after this point
it's been a pleasure to be around him
and he's gonna be a hell of a player
he's still developing obviously but
early early uh early thoughts are great
he's done a great job and
um it's been fun okay so let me hit the
wayback machine with you for a minute if
if you don't mind as i'm sure you knew
something like this would be coming and
i appreciate you calling into this show
is when when did things maybe dawn on
you
here in southern california that your
time with the rams was coming to an end
when might that have dawned on you jared
goff
um you know it it's funny because i i
tried so much to not
talk about this and then i'm so you know
bored and thinking about the future but
to be honest it was i i had i had no um
i had no inclination of it it came
somewhat from left field um when it
happened but again
things happen for a reason i'm excited
to be out here everything's been great
um
i had a lot of fun there like i spoke
about early on after the trade
a lot of good moments a lot of good
times and and it's it's in the rearview
mirror at this point
no i know you're you're a page turner
and things of that nature
um is there anything that occurred
during the playoffs that gave you an
indication that things were coming to an
end
none no and i and again rich i i
appreciate you i know you have to ask
the questions yes
i'm i'm so excited to be here man i had
a lot of fun there there was a lot of
good times obviously it ended sour and
um i think to answer your overall
question no there was not any
inclination
um anything like that was coming but
again it's it's what happens and
um i'm happy to be here okay i
appreciate you giving me that second
bite to the apple jar
i appreciate that oh i'm trying
[Laughter]
so am i so uh now now then uh
uh a new start in in a new division in a
new world
for you what well how how do you go
about
um you know computing all of that and
living it every single day jared um
yeah it's a transition just like
anything else i think anytime you
you play professional sports you're
you're available to
have to have a transition like this and
i think it's something i've embraced
something i've really enjoyed like i
mentioned
michigan's been fun detroit's been
awesome um the people here in this
building have been a lot of fun to be
around and it's really been a breath of
fresh air for me it's been it's been a
really
new energy feeling and um something
that's been really exciting
and uh tell me about uh your running
back deandre swift
um again you were in uh los angeles last
year
he had uh an interesting season somewhat
injury marred but then also
flashes of exactly what the lions have
been looking for at this position what
about
this georgia bulldog from your eyes now
that you're you're
right there on the ground jared yeah
he's been he's been a lot of fun to be
around he's a great player
great great athlete obviously you can
make all the plays you want i think
seeing him every day on the field
has been fun fun for me to be around and
and you know you
i i saw him from afar but i didn't i
didn't know much about him until i got
here
kid works hard kid does his job and is a
hell of an athlete a hell of a player
and
i know we'll rely on him heavily this
year okay and hawkinson as well he's a
pretty big target
and uh he's also shown some flashes to
say the least
at that position yeah dj's a great
player he's obviously had some great
success already and um
i hope we can keep building on it you
know he's a guy we'll feature a lot i'm
sure and
has done a great job up to this point
again everyone's everyone's been great
it's been a lot of fun you know
learning new teammates you know finding
out about their interests and about
their lives and
and at the same time getting work done
on the field okay and then you know
you're you're i'm sure of course aware
of
the lions history and how uh everybody
wants to page turn their
as well along with you how do you view
your role in creating a culture
a new culture there what uh the coach
has told you
about what he wants your role to be on
that front jared goff
yeah i mean just first foremost on the
quarterback so you know with that comes
the leadership position and
um obviously there is a there is a
culture shift that that we are working
on and trying to try to put
you know one foot after another and
every day it's something else and it's a
lot of hard work that takes place in
order to do that but
um i'm not naive to it i've i've seen it
done at cal it was something similar
with the rams and
um having that those experiences to draw
and i think does help for me personally
but
ultimately just just be the best i can
be every day be the best teammate leader
person i can be every day and
be consistent jared goff a few more
minutes left here with the detroit lions
quarterback
right here on the rich eisen show uh and
then your
your offensive coordinator anthony lin
um what is he bringing to the table what
can you tell us and everybody in detroit
what the offense is going to look like
give me some concepts if you will
uh put out on the table we're going to
see best you can here yeah we've been
we've been uh working through it this
spring and then all the way up
until now and i think you know it's been
fun working with him his experience
obviously in the league
has been been for a long time and has a
lot of knowledge and um
you know i i think i spoke about this
earlier on off season but
you know he calls it multiple express
principles and that's really what it's
been
being able to get the ball of different
guys in space and and you know throw the
ball down the field and
we're in shotgun we're under center it's
a big mix of things and it's constantly
a work in progress but it's been great
all right i'm gonna take a third bite
here do you guys ever sit around and say
look what
we're doing here together small world
crazy things happen
roads traveled you guys ever sit there
and thank two guys
um yeah but i think it's no different
than him or anyone else in the staff i
mean
i was i was around dan at the pro bowl i
was you know around
aubry with with la aubrey pleasants our
tv coach here now so
yeah it's it's no different than any
other guy i think you're in this league
long enough you cross paths with some
guys but
yeah i guess it is unique that we were
both coming from my life yeah i know
from that building what do you think
it's going to be like october 24th when
you're back in that building
jared goff for you oh man i don't know
who we played before that we got about
six games before that i believe right
i've actually got the schedule right
here up in front you play uh the
cincinnati bengals right in front of
them
and the minister all we're worried about
right now richard
are you taking it one game at a time
with me right now jared
that's gonna be your answer this is a
problem interviewing a cal berkeley guy
sometimes you know what i mean like you
think you you're
you're you're one step ahead of me jared
that's a problem but i'm a michigan man
so that
i also know the boots on the ground
there for you as well and how fans are
you know they're they're there and
genuine genuinely
we've got a lot of work to do before we
get to week seven or whatever week eight
i'm not sure what game it is but
um genuinely there's a lot of work to do
before that and and obviously we're
focused on
the off season okay and so uh what uh
what's
what happens after this week for you
jared what's your map it out for me
do you take some time off you're going
to tap out you're going to what are you
going to do
what do you got for me afterwards we'll
come here for a little bit i believe
next week and then
yeah i'll take it probably a week just
to chill and get back to work start
training again and
get ready for training camp okay you're
gonna spend any time uh you know
uh with uh at the university of michigan
at any point in time jared you wanna
take a trip up there
i don't know i don't know i don't that's
right i forgot that's your that's your
school that's nice
i don't i don't plan to right now but uh
maybe maybe at some point if i if i need
any
help around there i know the guy to talk
to you i'm the guy jared
i'm the guy seriously uh it's a it's a
it's an awesome state
it really is it's just a yeah it's it's
right there
like i said in the middle of the country
and everybody
is very prideful and rightfully so um
and then just like they're dying they're
dying for the
lions to to do what they're they've
always wanted them to do which is
you know obviously win a championship
you've got a lot of
fans are putting a lot on you i'm sure
jared
it's great you know wait playing
thanksgiving as well have you ever
played on thanksgiving
has that ever happened i haven't no it's
been my first time that's something i'm
excited for and
my family's definitely excited okay hey
jared you take care of yourself man
thanks for the time i greatly appreciate
the uh the
the time right here in the middle of the
mandatory mini camp you keep doing what
you're doing
no problem hey thanks for having me you
got it that's jared goff detroit lions
quarterback right here on the rich eisen
show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here